The late 19th century in Germany gave us a new kind of prisoner, the private shellard.
Not a monk, not a hermit, but something far more insidious, the private scholar.
These men didn't just avoid the world. They weaponized knowledge against it.
They spent decades in libraries surrounded by towering shelves of books they would never read,
much less publish. Their lives were a performance of endless preparation.
The world called them scholars. They called it research. And the truth, they were the original
architects of what psychologists would later name, asterisk, the intellectualization of avoidance.
Here's how it works. You feel the pull of action, the need to start something, to finish something,
to live in some small way. But first, you must arm yourself with understanding. So, you dive into
books, not one, not two, a dozen, each one deeper, more contradictory, more important than the last.
By the time you synthesize their arguments, your original impulse is dissolved into a mist of
second-hand wisdom. The project? Forgotten. The party? You're still reading about the neurology of
anxiety. The laundry? That's just a distraction from the real question. What is the point of this
in the heat death of the universe? This isn't laziness. This is high-resolution avoidance.
While others waste time on TV, you waste time on thought. You build cathedrals of logic to justify
standing in the dark. And the best part? You feel intellectually superior while doing it.
The instructions are simple, really. First, the research rabbit hole. The moment you consider
action, you pivot. Find a book on the subject. Then another. Then another that disagrees.
By the time you've reconciled them all, your energy is spent. The project? Still in its cradle. Your life?
Still in stasis. Second, the existential reframe. That email? Mundane. The laundry? A farce. But ask
yourself, truly, ask what meaning these things hold in the grand scheme. Suddenly, the very idea of folding a
sock feels like a betrayal of cosmic indifference. You're not avoiding your life. You're philosophizing
it into oblivion. Third, the systemic shield. Failure isn't personal. It's structural. The raise you
didn't get? Not your fault. It's late-stage capitalism. The friendship you never nurtured? Implicit bias.
This is the ultimate escape hatches. This is the ultimate escape hatch. No agency. No responsibility.
Just endless analysis of why the world is broken while you remain untouched. Finally, the metacognitive
loop. You don't just think. You think about thinking about thinking. I am currently experiencing
cognitive dissonance regarding my desire for a sandwich. And there you stay narrating your own
paralysis like a documentary host who's forgotten the plot. The endgame? You become a shaller of the void.
A human encyclopedia of why things are impossible with no clue how to make them possible. You've
mastered the art of narrating your own collapse in the vocabulary of genius. And the worst part?
You're not even unhappy. You're elevated. You're deep. You're the kind of person who turns a dinner
decision into an intellectual inquiry, spending the evening in a state of high-quality decision stress.
Because why rush? Why act? The bridge is built. You just decided not to cross it. Philosophy,
after all, is the art of building a bridge across a river and then deciding to never cross it,
build the bridge, and stay on the shore forever.